[Music]  the more i live  the more i find that if you have good  friends in your corner anything's  possible  carrie party of three  the future is unwritten because we're  all at different stages of life tonight  bring your a game  come on in  how many dating apps are you on i'm just  waiting for someone to create a dating  site that's called here's the man you've  been searching for sima  this is x y and me what about you carrie  have you ever masturbated in a public  place  not since barney's closed  oh honey i'm home  i remember when you kept your sweaters  in the stove  they're always going to be roads not  taken so you can't have it all no you  can it's just really hard  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  and just like that  after all the years  and all the changes  you're still  you hello lovers  [Music]  you